[Musique]
vous publiez une annonce sur une
plateforme de vente en ligne disons un
ensemble de salles à manger attention la
table est mise pour une autre arnaque un
supposé acheteurs empressé est intéressé
va vous écrire j'achète puis il va
expliquer qu'il travaille beaucoup et va
vous proposer de vous envoyer une
entreprise de livraison reconnu le
livreur va vous donner une enveloppe
d'argent comptant et prendre l'immeuble
eeci l'utilisation des marques de
confiance c'est l'ingrédient qui
permettra de vous faire gober la suite
du menu parce qu'on va d'abord vous
envoyez un courriel aux allures officiel
vous demandant de remplir un formulaire
et c'est là qu'on vous sert le plat
principal pour protéger l'immeuble
l'entreprise de livraison va vous
demander de payer une assurance pour
vous rassurer l'acheteur vous dira qu'il
va vous rembourser en ajoutant le
montant dans l' enveloppe si vous avaler
ça vous êtes cuit vous serez toujours
coincés avec votre table et aurait perdu
l'argent versé pour la fausse assurance
rappelez-vous la vigilance a bien
meilleur goût passés le mot
[Musique]